[Music]
medical marijuana is already a
multibillion-dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this look most people will tell
you as Alden walked on the moon but even
a complete idiot will tell you Neil
Armstrong did it first and do you know
why he went first there was the dish's
hedge open and hiss because you push
buzz older and the [ __ ] out of the way
and seize history by the ball sack I'm
satisfied
[Laughter]
[Music]
look man you're in some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy do them cash pool
no I'm saying you're poor poor tomorrow
you can apply Mexico what we want you to
hand-deliver the weed pill formula to
the lab yes and I'm not supposed to
touch the mini but but I'm going to do
it you know I don't even care anyone
doing it I'm having a [ __ ] cry-baby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out
gonna give it we sold a little product
to the cartels but when we cut them off
they got a little angry I know a guy
I'll track down dictators back to find a
guy in middle man what do they want
Michael children I need to keep track
you can't scare me
details of the big bag hotels I don't
things work not in Mexico Harold Harold
you really believe in God of course I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in good I guess I kind of do
but not things you can just have to get
better for you trust me I have good
instincts
[Music]